[Música]
cuando me invitaron la verdad es que
estaba en un momento de inconsciencia
luego entré a uno en una etapa de
entusiasmo y luego viene el
extraordinario trabajo que han estado
haciendo este equipazo para promover
este evento y entra uno en pánico y
ahorita estoy en el momentos en de
empezar la plática entonces si yo fuera
director de cine ahorita tendría una
claqueta aquí y diría luis gerardo
gonzález herederos toman 55 porque yo
creo que son las veces que he dicho esta
conferencia
algunas veces sale muy bonita en no
todas espero que esta sea de las buenas
y la verdad es que es muy fácil porque
en una audiencia como ustedes que nos
transmite una vibra tan padre y que hay
tanta gente con la que me ha tocado
coincidir en el camino pues me siento
como en familia yo soy profesor soy
profesor por vocación y me ha tocado dar
clases a niños adolescentes jóvenes
adultos y es desde ese contexto y con
esa voz que hoy vengo a compartir este
mensaje con ustedes no es solamente mi
voz la verdad es que en esta plática yo
reconozco las voces de muchos que han
sido mis maestros desde mi papá que es
maestro desde mi esposa que es maestra y
de muchos otros que en el camino me han
ayudado a ser la persona que soy hoy y
quiero empezar esta plática como muchas
veces empiezan mis clases con una
pregunta y la pregunta es muy sencilla
si pudieras definir un momento en donde
empieza la historia de tu vida ya nos
hablaba guita de las historias
qué momento sería
cuando yo le hago esta pregunta a mis
alumnos muchos de ellos me han dicho
pues a lo mejor pues mi primer recuerdo
mi memoria temprana de esa primer
memoria de la infancia otros dicen no
uno la historia mi vida empieza cuando
yo nací cuando yo vine a este mundo y
otros dicen bueno a lo mejor mi historia
de vida empieza un poquito antes cuando
mis papás se conocen o cuando mis papás
se enamoran y cuando dicen eso muchos
empiezan a decir es cierto porque
también es parte de mi historia personal
no solamente la historia de mis padres
también de mis abuelos y a lo mejor de
mis ancestros
y a lo mejor podríamos ir más atrás que
tal que nuestra historia personal
coincide con el inicio de todas las
historias que tal que nosotros
pudiéramos asumir que nuestra historia
personal empieza en ese momento en la
historia del universo donde hay una
singularidad con una gran densidad una
gran temperatura porque por razones que
desconocemos explota y en un proceso que
ha tardado más o menos 13 mil 800
millones de años ha ido dándole forma a
todo lo que nosotros conocemos hoy al
universo en el que vivimos
para representarlo y tomar un poquito la
dimensión de esa historia que tenemos en
cada parte de nuestro cuerpo en la
década de los 80 se hizo muy popular
esta representación del calendario
cósmico lo que trata de hacer el
calendario cósmico es condensar esa
historia de casi 14 mil millones de años
de historia en un calendario de 12 meses
y entonces el primer instante de ese
calendario del primero de enero de ese
calendario es el big-bang y de ahí van
apareciendo diferentes acontecimientos
que nosotros reconocemos importantes en
nuestra historia por ejemplo en el mes
de mayo podemos encontrar el surgimiento
de la espiral de la vía láctea
en el mes de septiembre vemos el
surgimiento en nuestro vecindario
cósmico el sistema solar y podemos
reconocer el planeta tierra y en el mes
de noviembre surgen los primeros
organismos vivos y en el mes de
diciembre será una explosión de vida
impresionante que da origen a un ser que
es consciente a un ser que es capaz de
pensar todo esto de reflexionar dice
carl sagan que nosotros somos polvo de
estrellas contemplando estrellas
también él dice hasta donde sabemos
somos la mirada la escucha la emoción la
voz de este universo y esa es una
historia genial
es una historia que los the big bang
theory' la serie tratan de condensar en
unos segundos y si tú te quedas viendo
todas las imágenes que aparecen ahí
hasta te puedes marear pasan tantas
cosas y justo cuando tú ves cada una de
esas cosas esa es la herencia de la que
yo quiero hablar en esta conferencia en
esta plática
nosotros somos herederos de una historia
cósmica en donde tuvieron que chocar
estrellas nacer morir la fuerza de
gravedad la temperatura para que podemos
habitar un planeta con las condiciones
exactas las condiciones de ricitos de
oro para que poder podamos estar aquí
para que pueda haber este tipo de vida
en este planeta pero no solamente son
esas historias cósmicas también son las
historias de las generaciones nada más
para que te des una idea para que tú
puedas estar hoy aquí para que cada uno
de nosotros estemos aquí tuvieron que
haber dos papás cuatro abuelos ocho
bisabuelos dieciséis tatarabuelos y si
nos seguimos así más o menos doce
generaciones que representan en la
historia de la tierra cuatrocientos años
son más de ocho mil personas ocho mil
historias para que tu historia puede
existir y esas historias son también
parte de tu historia personal
y la pregunta importante es para qué
porque cada parte de nosotros cada celo
en nuestro cuerpo es heredera de esa
historia y usted me van a decir las y
las herencias no siempre son buenas
estoy de acuerdo no sé si han visto ese
concurso en donde compran bodegas y
entonces compran bodegas pensando que
puede haber tesoros pero a veces
solamente encuentran basura y también en
nuestra historia como humanidad tenemos
basura pero también tenemos historias
muy interesantes
si nosotros observamos el planeta
ahorita hay crisis económicas
ambientales sociales políticas muchas
cosas que nos desaniman
pero por otro lado también hay muchos
expertos que dicen que en la historia la
humanidad
no hemos tenido una etapa de tanta
abundancia de tanto bienestar como
ahorita nada más vean expectativa de
vida si nosotros le preguntamos a
nuestros abuelos o incluso si les
podíamos preguntar a nuestros bisabuelos
seguramente nos dirían estamos bien
viendo cosas que nosotros nunca
hubiéramos imaginado
para aquí
ahora como las herencias las herencias
no solamente son para una persona y ahí
vienen los problemas esta herencia la
compartimos con más o menos 7.000
millones de seres humanos en el planeta
somos muchos
y frente a una herencia normalmente los
seres humanos podemos tomar dos
actitudes no les quiero platicar las
actitudes las vamos a actuar entonces
fíjense bien lo que vamos a hacer va a
ser un juego porque yo en mis clases
como juego si mis alumnos aquí no me
dejarán mentir entonces el juego es muy
sencillo le vamos a dedicar solamente 30
segundos porque nada más tengo 12
minutos entonces como como es el juego
van a formar parejas así literal con los
que estén cerquita que le tengan más
confianza y van a poner sus manos así
como para ser vencidas entonces voy a
pedir que colaboren porque luego tenemos
que hacer el conteo grupal vale entonces
ojalá que a todos les toque tomar la
mano de alguno de sus vecinos con
confianza este puede ser sí y fíjense
bien cómo se gana en este juego bueno
más bien qué es lo que tienen que hacer
tienen que acumular en 30 segundos la
mayor cantidad de puntos posibles cómo
se ganan los puntos si tú logras doblar
la mano de tu compañero es un punto pero
si él logra doblar la mano también es un
punto ok entonces tengo un cronómetro ah
y 30 segundos lleven la cuenta es muy
importante
30 segundos ahí está el reloj muy bien
ahí veo las fuerzas y hay batallas
impresionantes excelente excelente
algunos no se dejan muy bien
hay algunos ganadores excelente
esas batallas allá atrás muy bien
les quedan 7 segundos para ganar la
mayor cantidad de puntos posible
tiempo perdón tiempo tiempo
un aplauso por esta participación súper
bien
y ahora vamos a ver qué pasó entonces
levanten la mano los que pudiendo jugar
porque a lo mejor ahí queda alguien así
entre todos que no pudo jugar desde los
que sí pudieron jugar que no tuvo ningún
punto
hay bastantes bastantes estuvieron
fuerte las batallas que tuvieron entre 1
y 5 puntos
ok ya - muy bien entre 6 y 10 puntos ahí
están los guerreros muy bien
11 y 15
poquitos jueguitos voy a ver si hay
alguien 16 o más ahora lee muy bien
grítenme cuantos pudieron conseguir en
30 segundos
100 hay entrevistas segundos
a lo mejor ahorita lo que está pasando
es que los que tuvieron cero poquitos
puntos dicen ir cómo lo hicieron
lo que pasa es que esta es una de
nuestras herencias nosotros hemos
aprendido a operar en dos modalidades
una modalidad que es la competencia y
entonces la competencia solamente me
preocupa mi objetivo no me preocupa el
objetivo del otro o la posibilidad de
que el otro también pueda ganar hay
contextos en donde eso es lo que se
espera en el contexto deportivo en el
contexto de una competencia de baile
eso te ayuda no a demostrar que el
trabajo que has hecho es un gran trabajo
pero en el contexto de construir
comunidad en el contexto de la sociedad
si yo solamente pienso en ganar para mí
en satisfacer mis objetivos ahí perdemos
todos
la otra modalidad es la modalidad de la
cooperación y en esa modalidad me
importa ya ganar pero también que tú
ganes entonces hay un momento en donde
me puedo dar cuenta de que no tengo que
pelear contigo de que podemos estar
haciendo cosas juntos y entonces podemos
hacer este movimiento y de repente ganar
100 puntos
eso que nos lleva al final en esta
herencia que tenemos podemos ser mis
reyes del universo explotadores abusivos
que pasan por encima de los demás que no
les importa incluso pues lastimar a
otros para lograr satisfacer sus
necesidades o podemos ser como estos
soberanos estos reyes que de repente
tienen la historia que cuando reciben
esa investidura lo hacen con un afán de
servir de valorar esa herencia de
apresar apreciar esa herencia y dejar
una herencia mejor para los que vienen
de atrás ya lo mejor por ahí debemos ir
nosotros convertirnos en guardianes de
esta herencia común hace ratito yo les
decía que soy profesor soy educador por
vocación y entiendo la educación no como
una transmisión de conocimientos sino
como la posibilidad de guiar de ayudar a
otros a crecer lo que es un poco la
etimología ayudar a crecer es como
cultivar tú no puedes estar jaloneando a
una plantita tienes que dar las
condiciones para que ésta plantita
crezca y en ese contexto todos nosotros
somos educadores todos nosotros ayudamos
a otros a crecer en nuestras familias es
muy claro pero en las escuelas en las
organizaciones en las instituciones
incluso en relaciones que pueden ser muy
casuales un buenos días una un trato
amable con una persona que no conocemos
puede ayudar
a crecer
yo a lo largo de estos años que me ha
tocado acompañar a alumnos he encontrado
que hay tres actitudes que ayudan a ese
crecimiento y son las que quiero
compartir a veces lo hago explícitamente
como ustedes que ellos se apropien de
esta herencia que la valoren y que hagan
algo con ella a veces es simplemente
hacerles la pregunta y para qué estás en
este mundo
esas tres actitudes espero y de hecho
este grupo de personas son un gran
testimonio cada vez que iban platicando
yo decía palomita palomita palomita
porque luego ellos nos están platicando
es justo eso primero es valorar la
herencia del otro el otro es igual que
tu heredero de esos catorce mil millones
de años de historia y si tú logras
relacionarte con la gente así yo creo
que cuando hacer las cosas muy
diferentes porque quién puede trabajar
quién puede esforzarse quién puede hacer
sacrificios por algo que no ama y todos
coinciden en esa parte del amor de la
pasión de la entrega la segunda actitud
que podemos tomar tiene que ver con el
animal
frente a mí han pasado un montón de
alumnos que llegan a platicar de sus
proyectos y yo la verdad es que veo la
nobleza de la intención la generosidad
de las acciones el deseo de construir
cosas que lo único que puedo hacer es
ver esa brasa que empieza a arder y
soplar le para que se convierta en una
fogata y que lleve esa luz y ese calor a
otras personas si se fijan lo que ellos
han compartido con nosotros es eso y yo
cada vez que los escucho digo yo quiero
seguir apoyando a los que quiero seguir
apoyando al toluca y quiero seguir ahora
quiero hasta hacer reuniones de ex
alumnos para hacer obras en las escuelas
y cada una de esas historias inspira le
quiero comprar sombreros a toallita no
es tener la capacidad de entender que no
tienes que ser protagonista de todo que
a veces también lo que se necesita para
construir comunidad es apoyar es animar
es soplar lea esas brasas para que siga
ardiendo y que se construyan esas
fogatas y por último persistir hay una
cita que me gusta mucho que dice cuando
arroja es una piedra el agua las ondas
tocan orillas insospechadas nosotros
como educadores es lo que hacemos
hay alumnos que son como grandes lagunas
y por más que echas piedras de repente
parece que no llega y hay otros que son
un terreno fértil que aunque dicha es
una piedrita de verdad que aún las
orillas padrísimas hugo por ejemplo y
aquí tengo otros alumnos que de repente
los ves comprometidos involucrándose en
cosas haciendo la diferencia que está
ahí está y ese es el trabajo que nos
toca seguir echando piedritas con
persistencia y también todas esas
historias tienen voy terminando yo creo
que hoy nos toca hacer valer esa
herencia
toluca este momento muy especial estamos
a 12 años de celebrar 500 años de
existencia
toluca desde el origen ha sido una
ciudad crisol de culturas ya nos
platicaba toñita la cantidad de culturas
que han cohabitado en esta zona y que
siguen habitando la que siguen dándole
vida ha sido un punto de encuentro un
lugar de negociación de diálogo y hoy en
esta reunión estamos haciendo honor a
esa historia de la ciudad pero tenemos
que seguirlo haciendo tenemos que seguir
siendo una ciudad que reconozca el valor
de lo que tenemos aquí decía el maestro
gerardo hace ratito de repente en toluca
nos decían que somos fríos y su
temperatura actual es templados no somos
eufóricos
porque también guardamos nuestro glamour
pero pero tampoco es cierto que somos
fríos y tenemos un montón de cosas
buenas yo les puedo decir a muchos de
ellos no tenía el gusto de conocerlos
personalmente y hoy estoy enamorado de
lo que hacen de sus proyectos y hemos
convivido solamente este día necesitamos
construir seguir siendo ese espacio de
diálogo de construcción de comunidad y
como le podemos hacer para hacer valer
la herencia haciendo valer nuestra
propia vida en esta historia del
universo que es una vida humana
la verdad es que una vida humana es
pequeñita hay una comparación que
podemos hacer si extendemos el
calendario cósmico en una cancha de
fútbol americano una vida humana perdón
la historia de la humanidad ocupa el
espacio de una mano
si nosotros consideramos que el
calendario cósmico este es el último
segundo o el primer segundo del
siguiente año nada más para darnos una
idea 500 años son más o menos un segundo
o sea hace cinco segundos nació jesús de
nazareno cuatro segundos nació jesús de
nazaret o sea una vida de una persona de
cien años y longeva es solamente un
parpadeo un cuarto de segundo y aquí
parece una paradoja porque les estoy
diciendo cada célula de tu cuerpo tiene
esta historia de 13 mil 800 millones de
años de historia pero al mismo tiempo
una vida humana puede parecer
insignificante en esa historia y yo te
quiero hacer una pregunta ha habido un
ser humano que impacta de manera
positiva a tu vida
estoy seguro que nadie diga que no y
entonces esas historias son esos
chispazos de luz esas vidas que son
fugaces pero que incluso tienen la
capacidad de iluminar la vida de otras
personas y de convertir nuestro momento
en la historia en un momento luminoso y
ese es el trabajo que tenemos que hacer
y lo tenemos que hacer juntos porque ya
no es suficiente hacer un esfuerzo
individual
tenemos que hacerlo conectados anudados
con otros y ya terminó hay una canción
que me gusta mucho no la voy a cantar
porque ya le dije atónita no soy tan
valiente no tengo tan buena voz pero es
una canción que es de fernando
delgadillo se llama hoy hace un buen día
y hay una parte en donde dice y cuando
fuimos a empezar y si nos hayan más bien
y si miramos hacia atrás de donde fuimos
empezar y encontramos los antiguos que
formaron un lugar que un buen ya se
marcharon y aprendimos a decir grandes
fueron los viajeros que cruzaron por
aquí
la canción sigue y habla de lo que hay
que hacer con las semillas que están
creciendo entonces lanza este reto y
dice si ellos los que vienen detrás de
nosotros miran hacia atrás de donde les
toca empezar y nos hallan a nosotros que
formamos un lugar que un buen día nos
marcharemos y aprendimos y tal vez
podrán decir grandes fueron los viajeros
que cruzaron por aquí
es lo que tenemos que construir agarrar
nuestra herencia valorarla hacer cosas
grandes con ella para poder seguir
nosotros entregando grandes herencias a
las generaciones que vienen y en eso
pues cuenten con nosotros yo creo que
estoy súper agradecido por poder
compartir este foro con gente a la que
le ha aplaudido de pie a la que les he
echado porras en el estadio gente que me
ha tocado escuchar sus historias en una
mesa familiar y decir me sentirme
inspirado y otros que a lo largo de este
proceso igual hemos colaborado juntos
hemos compartido el salón de clases o
ser jueces en algún concurso ya los que
incluso no tenía la oportunidad de
conocer que sus historias en este
proceso han sido una gran inspiración y
agradecer también a este equipo de locos
soñadores geniales
que están haciendo algo simplemente por
amor y usted lo vieron al inicio con
hugo entonces cuentan con nosotros
seguimos anudados y seguimos
construyendo estas grandes historias
para nuestra ciudad para hacer ese
chispazo de luz en nuestra historia
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]